>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Nicholas Brown: Good
evening, welcome everyone.
Nice to see some friendly
regular faces
and also some new folks
out here tonight.
My name is Nicholas Brown,
I am a music specialist
and concert producer
here at the library.
I'm very pleased to introduce
to you two wonderful colleagues.
On my far left is Herve
Boutry who is director general
of Ensemble Intercontemporain
[foreign language].
Yeah, I really have been
practicing it's kind of funny.
And to my immediate left is Matthias
Pintscher who is the music director
of Ensemble and also a
distinguished composer.
We're very thrilled to have them
both here to share some thoughts
with you this evening before
a super exciting concert,
which is the Ensemble's DC debut.
So let's kick it off.
Tell us a bit about your
impression of DC so far.
No politics.
>> Herve Boutry: Well we
arrived yesterday night
and we enjoyed fantastic acoustic
of the [inaudible] auditorium.
And we are very happy
to be here because it's
for us also the conclusion of a
wonderful tour through the US.
We started some days ago,
two weeks ago in Berkeley,
we had four days residency
there and four days
in Chapel Hill, North Carolina.
And these residences we have
interactive with the universities
and had a different focus on the
repertoire because it was of course,
more contemporary on one side.
We have a very contemporary
program tonight.
>> Matthias Pintscher: We
have so classical tonight yes.
>> Herve Boutry: But tonight we
have also classical repertoire
and so that's my first
impression or expression
from Washington, DC up to now.
>> Matthias Pintscher: I mean, it's
obviously beautiful to see this city
and I've been to DC many,
many times, but I think never
at that time of the year where
you see the beautiful foliage
of the leaves and we're very
fortunate with the weather
and the sun, which is also kind
of irritating and confusing
because it is just not normal.
And I don't really know
what you think of it.
But I mean right now we just
walked over and I was going
through some manuscripts
of Beethoven and Schoenberg
and Copeland and we received
the news from what is going
on in this very moment in Paris.
So it is emotionally very
how can I even put it,
I'm really moved and now.
But this is exactly what makes an
artist because now we may or have
to play this concert with
all these emotions that go on
and it's the only thing we can do
because we're not in
Paris right now.
So what we can do is just to keep
doing exactly what we believe in,
which is play the music
in the most painful way
so it brings people together.
I I'm really emotional it's very
disturbing what is going on.
>> Herve Boutry: You
have to explain.
>> Nicholas Brown:
Yeah, I got the feels
that all you needed info,
so don't worry about it.
There's been new within
the last couple of hours
of a major series of
attacks in Paris.
And if you have people living in
Paris, please you want to check
in with them as soon as you can
and it's not clear who or why
or the extent or anything
like that yet.
So it's -- tonight will
probably be a very difficult
and emotional evening for everyone
who's going to be on stage.
So with that note.
With a program like this evening's
where there's some very highbrow
art music that is, you know,
the creme de la creme
in terms of repertoire
and then we have some
really great new repertoire.
What can we gain in terms of human
experience from this type of music,
particularly tonight's program?
>> Matthias Pintscher: We
gain from it what we have
and it brings us directly to the
question that's being put out over
and over again like when
audience members ask me
or someone what should we listen
for, can you tell us something
that helps us to be
guided through a piece.
And I said well you guide
yourself, you listen with your ears
and you listen with the
qualities that you have.
I mean listening means to involve
yourself and with all great art
and it could be visual, it could
be sonic you find something
about yourself and it's not really,
it's kind of the artist is
stepping back and hands it over.
And think that is what makes
it very, very beautiful
and music describes time.
So the one thing we
have to accept is
that someone else has defined
a certain span of time for us,
which nowadays seem to
becoming something that's almost
uncomfortable because we are
so used to being in control
of how we define the flow of time.
We zap through something, we stop
something, we turn something off
and when you listen to sound
and music you can't do
that, you have to sit there.
I mean you can walk out, but
you have to listen to 13 pieces,
13 minutes or 25 minutes
or 70 minutes of music
that someone has designed
and conceived for you
because he believes or she in
how that time is happening.
So it enables us to
completely let go
and I think that's a
beautiful condition.
And people sometimes
feel the opposite
that they don't feel
qualified enough
because they might not know enough,
but every one is the most
qualified listener anyway,
there is no such thing
as a qualification.
You can know more about music,
but it doesn't help you
to understand music.
So just listen and listen to
what you have and it's that easy.
>> Nicholas Brown: Thank
you that was really great.
Maybe to switch back
to regular topics now
because I guess we're going
to get pretty emotional here.
But Herve, could you tell us a
bit about how your relationship
and the Ensemble's relationship
began with Matthias and how
that grew into his current
role as music director.
>> Herve Boutry: I have been with
this Ensemble already 20 years
and I have been very close to Pierre
Boulez when he asked me to come.
And I must say it is what we live at
the moment is a very fortunate time
because after so fantastic
years we are now getting
like any organization you
have changes, evolution
and we have the impression now
that Pierre Boulez is no longer
in the condition to be
very present with us.
He's of course, in in contact with
us, but not physically present.
And we have the impression to become
adult and not to be the children
of Pierre Boulez and this
has been enhanced very,
very strongly from the moment
when Matthias Pintscher has been saw
sharing destiny because it happened
like good food or we say in French.
In 2011, we appointed him
on June 12 and he started
with the Ensemble in 2013.
And I say that because it is not --
I want also to make a distinction
between what an ensemble looks
like, we are not a small orchestra.
We are a group of soloists,
a group of individuality,
strong personalities and what is
very important in such a group is
to be able to always ask yourself
why are you performing it together.
And when you have somebody
like Matthias,
when you have these personalities
at this very moment I have the
impression you are on the right wave
to go very much further
in aesthetically,
musically in the artistic
experience.
That's my statement
now if you ask me
about my relationship
with the Ensemble.
>> Nicholas Brown: Is there a
noticeable change in the focus
of the Ensemble now
and moving forward
versus in the past few
tenures of music directors?
>> Herve Boutry: Yeah,
there is a very big change
because it's not only the music
directors it's also the world
which has changed.
And the music world is
changing, I mean all the time.
And I think the 10 last years it
has been very obviously opening up.
The music world is
going from a more --
from a quite segmented attitude in
the past where modern institution
of people were modernists.
And now you have all classical
or [inaudible] to be authentic.
And now you have a different trend
which is to try and go to the root,
to the essence of the
music and to try
and find not a common denominator,
but a stronger experience,
particularly in this time where
internet where one can imagine
that 15 or 20 years ago we didn't
have internet as we have it now.
And it's absolutely
obvious with young composers
that they are writing in the
world with internet differently
than they were writing before.
The relationship with
the others has changed
and that's also explaining
the evolution of the Ensemble,
the Ensemble is an institution, a
contemporary institution and has
to move forward in this
environment and tries to do it
on the most pertinent way.
>> Nicholas Brown: Do you feel
a weight on your shoulders
as a successor of Boulez
in your role?
>> Matthias Pintscher: I
would rather, honestly I hope
that does sound arrogant because
I really don't mean it that way.
But I almost feel more encouragement
than weight because everything
that Boulez cared about is the
passing on and the sharing.
He might be even the only one
who has been almost aggressively
curious about what we do.
And all these encounters I
had with him and everything
that built our friendship and our
connection is based on his curiosity
of hearing me what I was starting
with, what I wanted to know.
And every time that goes years back
when I was conducting a major
new work of the repertoire
of the 20th century, I'm
talking about [inaudible].
He was so generous to share his
time with me and I most went
to Baden-Baden and we sat there
on his [inaudible] couch for hours
and hours and hours and shared.
So I rather feel a tremendous
enlightenment than the weight.
But of course and but he would be
really, really he is very excited
to see that we're moving things
forward whatever that means.
Because the movement itself of
going forward and I'm not talking
of avant-garde, but just the
keeping, that fact the condition
of keeping walking
is way more important
than the sensation of arrival.
Fulfillment puts everything
in question,
we always go back to the score.
And, you know, we're an institution
that is living on the basis
of all the scores that
have been conceived
and that have been
purchased right now
and hopefully will be
written in the future.
This is Boulez, Boulez is look at
the score and take it from there.
And it's not about me and how I
define that [inaudible] because I
like it that way or no, it
needs to come out of the score.
And I'd rather take that as a
tremendous potential of inspiration
than feeling intimidated and I
hope you understand it [inaudible].
>> Nicholas Brown: Oh yeah, I
think it's wonderful to hear
that perspective because
at least people that come
up through the US system and
knowing whatever happened
with in [inaudible] there's just
this aura around him that from
when you actually hear from someone
who knows him and interacts with him
on a very personal level that
sort of being isn't the reality.
So it's such a treat for
us to have you all here
to give us the real honest
perspective on his legacy.
Tell us a bit about your recent
performance of [inaudible] in Paris.
>> Matthias Pintscher:
Well [inaudible] is some people
consider it as his opus maximum and
but he wrote many opus
maxima or maximi,
opi maximi is that the Latin
plural [inaudible] said that.
But [inaudible] culminates
in an ingenious way
of really combining the electronics
and real sound to a level
that is maybe really unbeaten.
It's a work that is driven
by a great sense for color
and virtuosity, which
are two aspects
that very much define partly
what we consider as French.
But underneath it there's is a
great level and depth of expression.
And I always like it very much
to compare Boulez to Ravel
because they are composed of their
personalities that were very,
very conscious on how
to set up a composition,
but then also to allow it to fly
and enhance the richness
that is living inside.
Very controlled from the outside,
but equally strong
emotionally on the inside.
And so in that aspect for me as
a colleague if I may call myself
so it is fantastic to sit
down and be a scholar and read
and analyze those scores,
but at the same time
when I can just abandon all
that and perform the music
from the performer's angle is
equally as strong and there's not
that much repertoire that is
being written nor has been written
recently that has both
those qualities
which are extremely
appealing to me personally.
>> Herve Boutry: I want
to add something which is
that Pierre Boulez is also a
personality who has a global vision
of his artistry and for him art is
not only writing music on a paper,
it's also conducting, it's
also working with musicians,
but it's also working
with architects,
with people from all
sorts of disciplines.
And there is a very
strong [inaudible],
which affects me very strongly of
course because it's the architecture
of the whole is a set of work
which has to be performed
with the ensemble in the middle and
the soloist around the audience.
And the electronics
transforms the sound
and the electronic is projected in
addition to the acoustic sounds.
And it is -- it was very obvious
this year we performed it three
times in very different places
and I know that it is a challenge
which Pierre considered
as part of his work.
This challenge to find
the best conditions
and among these three hall we
had a hall which was very reduced
and without big interest.
We had a fantastic
place in Amsterdam,
which was originally a [inaudible]
I don't know what it is, you know,
a tank where you put the gas and it
has been transformed in concert hall
or performance place
which was fantastic
because it's completely symmetrical.
You have the ensemble in the middle,
you have 1,200 people around.
But more fantastic
was the performance
at the Philharmonie de
Paris which is a new hall
which has been opened
in January this year.
And I dare to say that without
Pierre Boulez this hall wouldn't
have been built.
It is really a hall which
combines all the characteristic
of what somebody like
him would have dreamt
and it is a fantastic acoustic
even for classical music,
but it offers also extraordinary
experience to the audience
when it is used for amplified music.
So it was a sort of consecration
actually of the different dimensions
of Pierre Boulez composer,
performer,
inspiratory of all sorts of people.
>> Nicholas Brown: Wonderful.
Could you tell us a bit about
your new recording projects?
I know there was a new release
just a couple of weeks ago
and hopefully there's more to come.
>> Matthias Pintscher: We
are obviously very excited
to sign a deal with
a recording company,
but also at the same time
you realize that it is kind
of outdated to produce records.
I still personally I'm
super old-fashioned anyway
because I'm still writing my
music with pencil and paper,
etcetera so I also still appreciate
having a CD in my hand and I guess I
like the booklet and I take it
out and I look at the pictures.
And I appreciate it,
I do appreciate it.
And also I appreciate the
fact that the CD has to be put
into a CD player that is mostly
with much better acoustics
than just listening to it on
your on your Mac Book Pro.
That's actually what does
happen if you download all
that on iTunes it's,
you know, it's just.
>> Nicholas Brown: Yuck
was the word up here.
>> Matthias Pintscher: So,
you know, taking the detour.
Yes, we are producing
now two CDs per season
with a French label
it's called Alpha,
it's part of the [inaudible] group.
And they give us --
it is not anymore?
[Inaudible] sorry, see
I'm getting it all wrong.
And they do something with us
and to us which is wonderful.
It's an institution to
have which they give us
like some [foreign language], they
give us a completely free hand
to choose and to present
of what we believe in.
And we both like the record
producers and us, the artistic team,
have come to the conclusion
that it might be interesting
to even compose the content of a CD.
So because nowadays in the real
concert world where people are less
and less inclined to subscribe
themselves to a concert series
of their favorite philharmonic
orchestra or whatever it would be,
but want to decide in the moment
that puts a weight on our shoulders
because we have to think
more and more carefully
of how we compose program a program.
And I think that should
naturally also reflect
on our choices of what
we put on a CD.
And mostly in the past we have
been talking about monographic CDs
like one composes, so you pair
Beethoven five and seven on one CD.
We do completely different because
we want to tell stories on CD
that could even comprise of the most
diverse compositional personalities,
but that in the end represent
something like a concert experience.
So you can basically, you can
also go to track four and listen
to [inaudible], but also
you can listen to that CD
as if you were to go to a concert.
And it is an idea and
we'll see if it translates,
but we just released our
first CD and so far it seems
to be a tremendous success.
But also on the base of the quality
of the playing, these players are
and you will hear it in a couple
minutes, are just phenomenal.
And it's a metaphor, but what
they touch really turns into gold
because there's so much respect
and tradition, comprehension of --
it goes almost 40 years back now
and we have a repertoire yes,
but we always built
on the repertoire.
And we're basically living in three
different times at the same time,
which is the present, but we
look back at the repertoire
that we have been part of
and have also generated.
And the foreshadowing which is we
are contemporary music orchestra,
we give out commissions,
we invest in the future,
we are investing a lot
of time in researching
of who should join our family
and who we support
and who we believe in.
So it's, you know, I'll close
it's a long answer for me.
But as we talk about Pierre
Boulez one of the things --
it was during our first lunch
we had 15 years back he talked
about how fascinated he
is by the architecture
of the Guggenheim Museum
in New York.
Where you wind yourself
up through that spiral
and you always [inaudible]
three times because you are here
and you look at that image,
but you can always look back
and still see what you have seen.
And you can already take a
sneak peek at what's coming up.
And so, you know, living
and perceiving and feeling
in three different times at the
same time is an ingenious concept.
And we are somewhat
trying to reflect
that in what we do with the CDs.
But you can also download
them on iTunes
for the people who [inaudible].
>> Nicholas Brown: How
has your live broadcasting
of concerts impacted your -- I
don't want to say name recognition,
but the way that your artistic sort
of vision is permeating beyond
your sort of core audience.
>> Herve Boutry: I don't know.
I think the broadcasting is
something which gives sort
of insider in listening,
in something happening
in the concert hall,
it's more documentation.
Because I am not a good
radio listener personally,
but though I believe that it is
very important for an institution
to be broadcasted for the people
who simply physically cannot
be in the concert hall.
But it's for me it comes in a
second row in the hierarchy.
In fact, I think we are
quite regularly supported
by the French public
radio, almost the majority
of our concerts are documented.
I find it very interesting, more
interesting the editorial aspect
of these specialized radio because
then they can provide something
which you cannot get
in the concert hall.
The conversation with the composer,
discussion of what you
have just heard and I think
in this respect it is very helpful
to disseminate what we are doing.
And I think it has really been
an important in the history
of the Ensemble and just n the
communication with the people.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great and
one other topic before we open
up to a couple questions.
What is your funding model
like because I know it's completely
different than what we're used
to here in the United States
for any of our music ensemble?
So how the US relies on
private funds generally
and some public grant money.
>> Herve Boutry: The
Ensemble has overall budget
of 6 million Euros a year, 4 million
is coming from public subsidies,
2 million are coming from
the income or from sponsors.
Actually the sponsors are a
ridiculous part among these
2 million.
And this is quite of course,
in comparison with American
institution it's like another planet
because I think for you the
proportion of subsidies is very low.
But among French or European music
institutions the Ensemble has a
quite challenging model.
There are very few orchestras,
public funded orchestras which have
such a big amount of income
from selling the concerts
and sponsorship.
And we are doing well, we cross our
fingers because it's always tough.
But the quality of the Ensemble and
the strength of our image is really,
I mean the core of
our economic success.
>> Nicholas Brown: Wonderful.
We have time for maybe
one or two questions.
So if you could raise your hand
and then my colleague Jay will come
to you with the microphone
in the back.
It looks like we have
up here in the front.
>> I'd like to ask a question
that explores what you mean
by musical understanding.
I believe your answer to that first
question pertaining more to the way
that people have their
own way of understanding.
But I got the impression from
the avant-garde of the 60's
that in many cases composers
were inventing their own language
sometimes with each composition,
whereas in other cases listeners
might want to look for illusions
or understanding based upon
all of musical history.
So any comments on that?
>> Matthias Pintscher: Well let's
maybe take this back a couple years
more and look at what happened after
the Second World War and I'm talking
about what has been written and
composed in Europe after the war.
And it seems like there was a
certain need for some objectivity
in what was composed because
everything had fallen apart
and the people were so speechless
and they didn't have the courage
or were not feeling strong enough to
just continue to be just subjective
and they needed to
objectify themselves.
And that's why that music
that was written in the 50's
and even the 60's so extremely
organized because maybe the majority
of the composers in Europe felt
like they needed to be able
to argument why they
put that F sharp here
and why they don't use the double
bases in the second movement.
And then all these decisions
had some argumentation handy
and ready to go.
And then with growing courage people
again all re-immersed themselves
in the pleasure of living
in diversity and then all
of a sudden even like the major
works of the 70's allowed again
that quality of physicality, color
and yes emotion to be re-included.
And that's why I always
plead my case to the listener
to please not be so
strung up on the fact
that we think we can
understand a piece of art
because that's what happens
to us when we go to school.
And when I was being taught how
to understand the second Viennese
school and in particular a work
by Anton Webern where, you know,
the melody is being played that way
and then is being played
backwards and then it's mirrored
and you just mark this all with
differently colored crayons
and [inaudible] and you think
you understand the piece.
That's what happened to me.
But no one was talking to us about
why that no flute with all that air
in the sound had this
erratic quality.
Why that low note on the [inaudible]
that D flat in opus 10 why
that note doesn't really --
the physically the
instrument doesn't allow
that note is not any more brilliant,
but it contains so much emotion.
And I wish and that's what
I'm doing with my students
at Julliard we do a completely
new way of analyzing a work,
we doing an erratic analysis,
no more crayons we just
talk about what we hear.
And I so wish that the listener
could just do exactly the same.
Leave your crayons at home and
no, I'm serious because we are
so determined by thinking analogies
and then feeling accomplished
when we understand a piece of art.
Like in the [inaudible] do you
understand the piece, I don't.
I mean I know a lot about it, but
I don't understand it any better
than you or you and I'm
exaggerating a little bit.
But I feel like it goes to
the listening and this is
where the emotions are kept.
That is the vessel of music.
And we are all emotional why
can't we allow that very naturally
to happen in that encounter
with sound
and even the sounds we
have never heard before.
It's a long discussion, but also
sometimes it just feels good
to impressively not discuss
it anymore because then you're
on yourself and I'm not guiding
you and I'm not telling you what
to listen for because
you have to listen.
And it's much more beautiful
if you listen to what you hear
than what I tell you what you
should hear in a piece of art.
>> Nicholas Brown: Great.
We have time for one
very short question
that will require a short
answer, so who's got that?
Great.
>> So there's a big difference
in terms of multilingualism
between Europe and America and
following on your comment just now
about auric training, do you have
any approach on how to train an ear
that has not grown up
listening to many sounds?
Is there a way of reprogramming
the ear?
>> Matthias Pintscher: [Inaudible].
Well I will be short,
I mean as I have to be.
But if as you say, if you
have little experience
or someone has little experience
or is not thoroughly trained,
it's even more fantastic because
you hear everything fresh.
It's like when a kid looks at the
first time at the Monet painting
or tastes a banana for the first
time wow, so there you are.
That was a short answer.
[ Applause ]
>> Nicholas Brown: Wonderful.
Well a huge thank you to
Herve and to Matthias.
Tonight is a very -- thank you,
tonight is a very historic occasion
for the library series to be able
to present the DC premiere of one
of the greatest most important
musical ensembles in the world
without question, it's
an objective statement.
And, you know, for all of us to grow
up just holding this huge regard
for your ensemble and to finally
have you here is just such a thrill
that I think hopefully all
of you are feeling as well
and I think it's going to be
quite a spectacular evening
for you musically.
So again, thank you
to Herve and Matthias.
>> Herve Boutry: Thank
you to having us.
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at LOC.gov.